hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts overcoming hurdles in
the study of rare diseases innovative
strategies for novel therapy development
presented by Joe Weimer
she is a senior director of therapeutic
development an associate scientist in
children's health Research Center at
Stanford Research I'm Marjorie Torres
the lab routes and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of the
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Jill Weimer I will now turn the
presentation over to her thanks Marjorie
and I just want to start by thanking lab
roots for asking me to host and present
as part of the seminar series and so
what I'm going to talk about today is
some unique approaches that my team has
had and taken over the last couple of
years in studying rare diseases and
before I jump into the meat of the
presentation I want to just give an
overview of sort of the big picture
approaches that my lab takes and
studying cortical development and rare
diseases so many people and a lot of
focus has been on in the last couple of
years and sort of this bench-to-bedside
approach and so my lab is particularly
interest
and how the cortex develops in the
mammalian brain and so we asked a number
of very basic questions about how
different signaling molecules tell stem
cells within the neurogenic niche to
divide and migrate to their final
resting place in the cortical plate but
while we're doing that we're also
looking at that interface of
translational science how do how do
mutations in particular genes or
disruption in some of these signaling
pathways lead to neural pediatric
diseases and how can we use this
knowledge gained from the basic science
to develop effective treatments for
these diseases so we have projects in
our lab that look at the proliferation
of neural progenitors or neural stem
cells or radial progenitors in the
ventricular compartment and so these
some of these projects look at small rho
gtpases or their regulators gifts in
regulating the placement of these neural
progenitors we have projects in the lab
that look at molecules that are
important for neuronal polarity and the
actual migration of these early
excitatory projection neurons along the
radial glial scaffold in particular
looking at a protein called marks that
we believe is important for early
progenitor polarization but once the
cells actually reach the cortical plate
is important for the differentiation of
these neurons and the extent of their
axons and the ultimate pathfinding of
those axons to their target in different
parts of the cortex or lower subcortical
structures we have projects in the lab
that ones that look at the actual
process of differentiation and long term
maintenance it's really within this
space that I'm going to focus a bulk of
our talk today so we look at factors
that are important for regulators
interact zonal trafficking so the
movement of organelles or cargo within
the axon and a number of the factors
that we look at in this regard are
involved in a rare lysosomal storage
disorder or a family of lysosomal
storage disorders called battens disease
and then also some implications in
neurofibromatosis type 1 and then lastly
how do those factors actually go
together to to form the
the mature cerebral cortex so focusing
on that last box and sort of the
differentiation and maintenance we're
looking at sort of how cargo moves
within axons and I think that often when
we're learning biology we learn that a
cell is round that all the organelles
are located around the nucleus so
similar to what I show you in this
cartoon that you have this yard that's
contiguous with the nuclear envelope and
positioned around that we have lysosomes
in mitochondria but neurons are very
unique they don't have this concentric
placement of organelles because
oftentimes the axons have to communicate
over very long distances and so those
organelles that are usually confined to
the cell body now have to be trafficked
within the axon and so we see movement
along a microtubule railroad track per
se of any anywhere from synaptic
vesicles to mitochondria the smooth ER
can flatten out into this space and
these these cargo are transported along
this microtubule by motor proteins
kinesins are often moving things away
from the cell body but there's also
return in this cargo to the cell body
itself in order to allow for signaling
back to the cell body or degradation of
proteins and this is usually done in
this anterior grade transport or sorry
retrograde transport it's often done by
motor proteins called Dining's
and so this movement of cargo is
absolutely essential we know that if we
disrupt this it can lead to a whole host
of different disease states the most
common that we're all familiar with is
the hyper phosphorylation of tau that we
see in tau APPA thiis or in Alzheimer's
disease tau is one of these proteins
that's responsible for binding to the
microtubule Network and stabilizing the
microtubule network and when you have
hyper phosphorylation or more disruption
in tau you lose the ability of that
cargo to move cargo away from the cell
body and so knowing that this process is
absolutely essential and so what we're
interested in the lab is understanding
how
proteins are responsible for serving a
sort of molecular tags or barcodes for
the cargo that's being transported along
this microtubule network and so we we
centered around a protein called crimp
tool and crimp to is shown here in this
smaller inset box of these organelles
being trafficked along the axon and
crimp to we kind of think of as the
railroad car itself so the the kinesins
as i mentioned or the dye means would be
kind of the train cars along this
microtubule railroad track and the crimp
too is serving as sort of the the
railroad cars and just like we think
about movement of traffic along railroad
tracks those cars can be loaded with a
number of different cargo and so I show
here just a number of the known cargos
four crimp to and I have many of those
listed on the right hand side and today
we're going to focus it in on this blue
represented cargo called CL n six I will
draw your attention to the fact that our
lab does a lot of work on
neurofibromatosis that I show here in
pink and it's a binding partner of crimp
to nf1 our neurofibroma n-- is the
protein that's mutated in
neurofibromatosis type 1 and so the sort
of innovative approaches that we've
actually taken to study studying nf1
focus around development of novel animal
models to study nf1 so like many
diseases when you mutate nf1 in mouse
the mice don't phenyl copy the disease
and so they many of the characteristics
that we see in the human disease don't
present in the mouse so recently in
collaboration with exemplar genetics a
team at the university of iowa and
collaborators in the university of
arizona
we've developed a porcine or a pig model
for neurofibromatosis unfortunately i
don't have time to tell you much about
that model today other than to say that
it does show a lot of the human-like
characteristics that are absent in the
mouse and presumably will provide the NF
community with a much more accurate
model of neurofibromatosis so the
remainder of today we're going to focus
on this interaction with si
and six and what I hope to do is kind of
take you through sort of our interest in
the basic biology and what we think
stealin sticks is doing in neurons but
then also kind of tell you how we've
used Ceylon sex as a central platform
for the study of batten disease and come
up with methods to accelerate the
development of treatments once we have
the the appropriate tools in hand so
stealin sex binds to this crimp to and
up to this point up to sort of when we
started studying this protein a few
years ago what was known about Ceylon
six is that it's an ER associated
protein and mutations in Ceylon six can
actually lead to two different forms of
batten disease and I'll talk a little
bit more about that disease in it here
in a second but it really opened to this
point folks had studied stealin sticks
in non-neuronal cells but one of the
things that's unique about that disease
is that although these mutated proteins
are expressed throughout the body really
the disease seems to be very specific to
the central nervous system particularly
in the loss of neurons and activation of
glia so we took a different approach and
saying could there be something that's
very unique about Sealand six and what
it's doing in neurons as compared to
cells within the rest of the body and
one of those things would be the
transport of organelles or cargo down
the axons and so we we kind of focus on
that let me step back and just tell you
about that disease because it's it's
oftentimes people haven't heard of this
very rare disease so bad disease it's
also known as neuronal steroid life of
Hewson osis and that name tells you a
little bit about the disease in that in
neurons and actually in other cells
throughout the body that disease
patients accumulate a see Roy door like
a few send this is a lipo pigment that
accumulates within the lysosomes so this
is considered lysosomal storage disorder
and there are over ten different
variants of this disease that are caused
by mutations and as many as fourteen
different genes and really sort of the
common element that leak
all the forms of baton disease together
are is the accumulation of that see roid
within the cells and then also a common
set of phenotypes that we'll talk about
here in a second
so overall the incidence rate of batten
disease is one in 100,000 live births
across these different variant forms but
collectively that makes it the most
common neuro pediatric neurodegenerative
pediatric disorder to date it's
incurable there are treatments that
treat some of the symptoms of the
disorder but ultimately it results in
premature death and just to give you
sort of a look at what happens to a
child with steel and six batten disease
so the the variant infantile form of
this disease the kids are usually born
fairly healthy around the age of three
to four parents start to notice that
they're having some language deficits
there they're having some motor deficits
not keeping up in terms of their
coordination and skills with their peers
and slowly they start to see a
deterioration and their cognitive skills
so this is a regression it's not a delay
in onset these kids are usually
functioning completely normal compared
to their peers and over a period of a
year they really start to regress within
a couple of years they've lost almost
all motor ability they're
wheelchair-bound they start to have very
severe seizures oftentimes they'll have
visual deficits and with the ceilin six
batten disease these children usually
don't live past their eleventh or
twelfth birthday so it's a horribly
devastating disease with no treatments
or cures and so what our lab has focused
on again as I said it's sort of the
basic biology and then the translational
so just to give you a road map we're
going to spend the first portion kind of
going through what we've done in the
basic biology and then we're going to
switch over to more translational
applications and really going back to
this sort of innovative approach to
accelerate the science so the first
question we started looking at is
whether this interaction with crimp 2
and CL n6 could mediate vesicular
trafficking
could it have this unique neuronal
function that I alluded to earlier and
so the first thing that we did is start
to look at how this
complex actually comes together and so I
told you that these crimp to molecules
often dot to kinesin light chains so we
used yeast two-hybrid a number of years
ago to show that sort of the linker
molecule to the microtubule network is
this selection kinesin or kinesin light
chain for that's able to bind to seal
insects and [ __ ] to and form what we
call the CCK complex and you can
visualize this here in neuronal axons
where we're looking at in the top panel
Ceylan six GFP with crimp 2 and you can
see that a subpopulation of the crimp
tube positive vesicles or puncta do
co-localize with crimp with seal and six
sit the same in the case for the panel
below that where we're looking at
localization of ceiling 6 and KLC 4 and
then with crimp 2 and KLC foreign in the
bottom panel really if you focus on that
there's a subpopulation of these cells
are these sorry cargo vesicles or puncta
that are triple positive for all three
of these molecules so i just want to
kind of pause here and say that as I
mentioned before crimp 2 has a number of
different interacting molecules that it
binds to so there was no assumption
going into this that all of the crimp to
puncta would be stealing sticks positive
but the same is the case for KL c 4
where KL t 4 also has a number of
interactional cargo that it's able to
bind to and transport besides crimped or
sealing 6 but there is a subpopulation
that are there positive we're fortunate
that there's a naturally occurring mouse
model for sealing six patents disease we
spent a quite a bit of time validating
that this animal model does recapitulate
the disease state that we see in sealant
six patent disease this includes retinal
degeneration that starts around three
months of age there's motor coordination
deficits that we can see between three
to six depending on what the test is
that we're doing they actually I show
here that the autofluorescence storage
material we can see at present five
months we pushed these limits and we can
see the autofluorescence storage
material actually accumulating in these
mites around one month of a
and then the glial activation the Astra
siddik a micro glial activation we can
see around three to four months of age
so really recapitulating these mice much
of what we see in the disease and so we
started to look at the neurons within
the brain of the ceilin six mutant
animals so if we take out primary
cortical neurons and put them into
culture and in this figure we're looking
at on the top one day after culture or
on the bottom looking at five days after
culture but you can see hopefully and
appreciate is that the ceiling six
neurons seem to be delayed in their
ability to break polarity and
differentiate and so on the left-hand
side you can see them very early on at
one day that there's a process that's
really kind of leading the pack at the
top that's that's going to become the
axon and if you look at five days in
culture you can see clearly an axonal
and acts on this delineated coming out
of the top of that cell where the
dendrites are kind of round the cell
body in the seal and six that seems to
be delayed and so in the one day and in
the five days you can see sort of this
delay in the ability of these cells to
polarize and sort of this this has been
quantified in terms of the extent to the
axon over time in the right hand bar
graphs so these cells definitely have a
delay in their maturation and ability to
develop their axons if we look at this
in a little bit more detail using a
Scholl analysis where essentially you
draw concentric rings around a mature
axon in this case we're focused really
on the axons I won't talk today that
there are some deficits also in the
dendritic branching but if we just focus
on the axons that we've kind of traced
in the little schematics on the left
hand side from wild-type and mutant
sealants six neurons what you see is
that there's actually a delay or a
deficit in the collateral branching
within the axon of these neurons over
time these were done in div seven
neurons and so you can see if you follow
just the traits for the show analysis
the orange is the wild-type and you can
see that as it move
away from distance from the radius from
the cell body that it's so throwing off
a number of collaterals and the ceilin
six neurons are always at a deficit
they're developing but they're just not
developing at the complexity of the
wildtype neuron so if you think about
this in the context of the disease if
you had this delay in the complexity or
sort of a inability to form the proper
connections your brain is going to be at
a disadvantage from the start so we can
also look at the connections that these
axons would be making some axons connect
on to dendrites typically at dendritic
spines so what we're showing here is
electron micrographs of golgi
impregnated dendritic spines you can see
these hair like follicles these intra
dick spines that protrude here just
we're focused on the primary dendritic
find primary dendrite coming out of the
top of the neuron and if you count those
dendritic spines you'll see that there
is a significant reduction in the seal
and six mutant animals suggesting that
they're making fewer synapses likely
because of the the deficits in those
axonal collaterals and axonal
connections that are forming so there is
a deficit in the cortical neuron
branching
if you look at a deficit in axon or axon
number ultimately that should lead to a
deficit in fiber tract formation and so
what we did was perform electron
microscopy in coronal cross-sections
across the corpus callosum and look at
sort of the the number of axons that are
actually crossing at the midline we did
this at one month and at ten month of
age and at one month there seemed to be
okay they seem to be able to get the
axons there interestingly there is a
deficit in the myelination or the myelin
compaction around these neurons even as
early as one month but if you look at
ten months there's definite reduction in
the number of axons that are crossing at
the midline and in that number that
myelin compaction is maintained so that
they're not maintaining these axonal
fibers across the midline as they would
in the wild type animal
so I apologize there supposed to be a
couple of video clips here but
essentially what we wanted to do next is
look into the actual trafficking of
these cargo vesicles and so we can use a
live die and called ER tracker and with
the assumption that ceylon six has been
associated with the ER now in the axon
itself there's two things that happen
with the ER there are small vesicles
that pinch off at the ER and our traffic
very rapidly along the axons but they're
also the smooth ER also flattens itself
and as contiguous within the axon itself
and in these live videos and I'll show
you fixed frames if we move forward here
what you can see is that above that
contiguous smooth ER there these very
distinct rapidly moving ER tracker
positive puncta that move within the
axon these if the video had worked I can
show you that these puncta actually
pause at areas that are presumably
synaptic connections they might pick up
a signal and then you see them quickly
move out of that space and continue down
the axon so if we take full of still
frames of these movies as I'm showing
here we can quantify the number of these
ER positive or ER tracker positive
vesicles in wild-type compared to Ceylon
six mutant animals and what we see is
that there's about half the number of
these ER positive vesicles that are
moving in the ceilin six mutant axons
suggesting that that impairment in the c
ck complex is precluding the ability of
these vesicles to move correctly so just
kind of thinking about how this
disruption might occur we started to do
a number of biochemistry experiments to
look at whether loss of ceylon sticks is
actually in interfering with crimped you
or the kinesin proteins so remember that
I told you that crimp 2 interacts with a
whole host of different proteins and if
we start to look at some of those what
we see is quite interesting so if we if
we immunoblot for the kinesins what we
see is a significant elevation of KLC
for
were in the axons or in sorry in the
brain of Sealand six mutant animals but
we see a reduction in some of those
other interacting proteins like nf1 and
SAR what SAR a1 which is a protein
expressed at the leading edge of the
axons so what this has suggested to us
is that the loss of ceylon 6 does
interfere with the repertoire of
proteins that crimp to would normally be
interacting with through these these IP
experiments and so suggesting that when
you lose Sealand 6 crimp 2 is kind of
binding tightly to the microtubule
network and the kinesin proteins and
losing its ability to interact with some
of these other forward-facing cargo
proteins like nf1 and sar1
so that's sort of been our working
hypothesis that you have as I show here
in this cartoon you have sealants six
that's transmembrane which I failed to
mention transmembrane to these ER
proteins and and we believe it's sort of
serving as a molecular barcode on these
ER drives vesicles to bind to crimp and
the kinesin proteins but what is this
cargo what are these ER vesicles we're
taking a number of both unbiased and
more targeted approaches to figure out
what this cargo is so one of the ways
that we're looking at this is to use a
technique called bio ID this is a
technology where a promiscuous biotin
ligase is fused to our seal n6 in this
case what we're doing is put in on that
C terminus or that yellow squiggly the
end of that yellow squiggly seal in six
proteins so that what it would be doing
is tagging any proteins that are luminal
to these ER Tracker positive vesicles so
that we'd be able to tag cargo and look
at that protein localization in order to
do this we're packaging our saline six
beer a bio ID protein into a av9 which
gives very specific neuronal
localization targeting through
intracerebral injections will then
isolate vesicles or synapses on will
press
and doom aspect to see what target what
targets are biotin elated in these
proteins to identify interacting
proteins or things that might be in
these vesicles we're also taking a more
candidate approach and I apologize these
bar graphs come up a little bit small
but what we've been doing is looking at
proteins who whose mutation lead to a
similar phenotype so I in the 14
different types of genetic types of
batten disease three of them are caused
by mutations in lysosomal enzymes ppt
leads to infantile batten disease
mutations in TPP one or sailin two are
the late infantile and then mutations in
cassettes and the lead to a fatal form
of battens disease and so we've looked
at the enzyme level of each of these
proteins or it's enzyme activity through
a cleavage off a tagging si and so
essentially on the left hand side in
these graphs we have enzyme activity
assays from whole grain for PPT TPP and
cassette Cindy and then on the right
hand side we have enzyme activity assays
for just synapses Omo preps
so although the proteins don't change
much in terms of their enzyme activity
in the whole brain what you can
hopefully appreciate is in all cases
there's a market decrease in the ability
of these enzymes to act within the
synapses Omo preps which would
presumably lead one to speculate that
possibly these proteins aren't making it
or being targeted correctly to the
synapse itself and so one possibility is
that ceylon six is responsible for
trafficking these particular enzymes to
the nerve terminal which would give a
similar disease phenotype so right now
what we're doing is going back and
looking by super-resolution microscopy
to see whether we can see Co
localization of these these enzymes in
sale and six positive vesicles within
the axon so stay tuned for that portion
of the story
so just to summarize the basic science
piece what we've shown is that ceylon
sticks
forms this CCK complex with crimp 2 and
KLC 4 and disruption and see on sets can
lead to a phenotype that's very similar
to what we see when with a loss of
function of crimp 2 in this fail -
failure to properly specify and maintain
axons so now kind of taking approach
where we've know a little bit about the
basic biology could we actually target
therapeutic complexes to this crimp -
associated stealing come a crimp -
associated complex as a potential
treatment for batten disease so we did
this we we wanted to select a target
that would do a number of different
things that it would help promote
neuronal survival it might decrease some
of the glial activation that I told you
was associated with batten disease that
it might increase the neurite stability
so we could get those those axons
branching and connecting correct
correctly that it might correct some of
that a our tracker vesicular trafficking
and it might increase crunchies ability
to interface with some of those other
proteins like nf1 or sar1 and loosen its
affiliation with the microtubule network
in the kinesins so there's a number of
compounds that have been shown to target
crimp - I list those here and they're
reviewed in a review article that we put
together with Rajesh Khanna a number of
years ago in future Neurology if anybody
wants to check those out but for the
purposes of our talk today we're going
to focus on this compound here called
LAN thiamine ketamine ester this is a
small molecule that binds to crimp - and
has been screened as a potential
therapeutic in a number of
neurodegenerative diseases including ALS
and mouse models of Alzheimer's disease
and so the other thing that makes LKR
made elke a particularly attractive to
us is that it's a cell permeating brain
penetrating orally by available compound
so oftentimes when or think about
therapies for the brain we have to know
whether they're actually readily cross
the blood-brain barrier or well
to deliver them systemically to the
central nervous system the great thing
about lke is that we can just compound
it into the Mouse Chow and more than
sufficient amounts are able to reach
those primary neurons work from Ken
Hensley's lab has shown that when you
when you throw this compound in this
case and the a and B on two neurons from
the dorsal root ganglia what you can see
is that it really enhances their ability
to send out your rights and that's
quantified in C interestingly this
compound - from Ken's lab that seems to
also have some neuro immune modulation
effects so in the ENS looking at sort of
the response in microglia or microglia
cell line to the release of nitric oxide
and sort of the ability of these cells
to respond so that's really for us seem
like a very appealing molecule because
we if we could increase collateral or
branching and then also dampen down some
of the neuro immune responses but one of
the other things that was particularly
interesting or attractive to us about
lke
is that it seems to have a counter
active effect to what we're seeing in
the disease State so recall that I told
you that in sailing six mutant brains
there seems to be an increased binding
to kinesin light chain and the
microtubule network and decrease binding
to proteins the sort of cargo crimp to
proteins like nf1
when you add LK it actually does the
opposite so it it it binds less to the
microtubule network and increases
affinity for program proteins like nf1
that I show here in these IPS so this
really told us that it might be able to
counteract some of those defects that
we're seeing in even the biochemical
level in the nf1 you see on six mutant
animals so we started a number of
studies both looking in vitro and in
vivo at how this compound would what a
work and so I'm going to show you first
just the in vitro studies so the left
two panels are those that I showed you
before where we were looking at
day 1 and day 5 and culture of cortical
neurons and then in the right hand side
what we have is those same mutant
neurons but now with the addition of lke
and what I hopefully you can see is that
the bar graphs here are just comparing
the mutant to the to the mutant with
drove so left hand side is the see on
six neurons and then the light blue
Carolina blue bars are the mutant cells
with the lke and what you can hopefully
appreciate is that in all situations the
addition of lke increases the initial
break and polarity deficit that we see
at day one and the continued maturation
of those axons out at day five
so LK in this case is able to rescue
that branching if we look at the Scholl
analysis again on top the light blue is
with lke the dark blue is what we had
shown before with the ingest some you
Tehran's and again the of the LK is
really getting the Scholl analyses of
the collateral branching back up to
wild-type levels so at the in the cell
culture level is able to correct the
axonal specification but what about the
inter axonal trafficking defect that we
saw with the ER tracker so if we look
now with the addition of lke
it's able to impart early restore the
number of these ER tracker positive
vesicles in the CL and six mutant
neurons now I think that probably part
of this is due that due to the fact that
not we're not completely restoring
sailin 6 so we're probably never going
to be able to get the sealant 6 positive
vesicles or cargo themselves moving but
what we're hopefully doing here is
actually correcting some of those other
cargo that are decreased so some of them
may be nf1 or the SAR one some of those
other crimp to binding cargoes that are
moving within the axons and partially
rescue in the phenotype so the next
thing we wanted to do is is look at is
this correcting any of the phenotypes in
in the animals themselves so
you dosed the animals with lke starting
at weaning and what we see in the top
hand panel is the survival of these
animals so the sealant six animals start
to take a turn for the worse around
eight to ten months and all of the
sealant six animals are dead by about
twelve to fourteen months of age and
there seems to be this slow progressive
loss of animals the addition of lke kind
of delays the initial death but
ultimately the animals do succumb to the
disease around the same age around
twelve to fourteen months of age so it's
not it seems to be delaying the early
phase or the early onset of the disease
but ultimately long term they're they're
succumbing to the disease the next panel
on B we're looking at some visual
processing so we use a system called the
visual cliff that I'm showing here so
the animals are placed in this chamber
it has a plexiglass bottom and typically
the wild-type mice will walk right up to
the edge of that cliff and they'll
they'll be a little bit nervous about
crossing over because they think they're
going to fall off the edge of the cliff
the seal and six animals are shown in
the middle gray bar have a hard time
distinguishing that cliff and so they'll
move back and forth across that boundary
space much more readily but the animals
that were treated with lke seemed to be
on par with the wild-type animals and in
their ability or crossover that space
and when we start to look at some of the
other parameters whether this is in C in
a radial arm maze looking at learning a
memory in late stages of the disease you
see a little bit of Correction with the
lke in motor performance or open field
we don't see quite as much of an
improvement with the lke although it
seems to be somewhere an intermediate
phenotype as shown in D and open field
and then in the bottom in rotor rod
testing to look at some of those motor
parameters
unfortunately the LK doesn't seem to
rescue any of the motor parameters and
the mutant animals in the those with
drugs seem to be in line with one
another whereas the wild-type is up
above and it maintains some of that
performance and coordination that you
would associate with rotor rod I just
show those behavior tests there so what
does it look like at the pathological
level so if we start to get into some of
the brain phenotypes so first time
showing you cd68 immunohistochemistry
and we we focus in our baton disease
studies in two different brain regions
the first on the left is a cortical
region s1 bf so this is a somatosensory
barrel filled cortex of the mouse and
this is from work of John Cooper and
some of our early characterization of
the mice sort of the seems to be the
targeted subcortical region that is most
severely affected and then on the right
hand side where that that somatosensory
cortex connects to in the thalamus one
of the sub nuclei the VPN BPL of the
thalamus is also an area that seems to
be very targeted and interestingly the
addition of lke actually seems to
exacerbate the microglial phenotype so
the lower right hand panel is the the
mutant animals with lke
compared to the untreated mutants in C
and in in all instances there seems to
be this significant elevation in
microglial activation and i will say
that even in the case of the cortex in
the wild-type animals just simply an
adding lke
can make these microglia hyper responses
now we don't know whether the microglia
are simply responding to the disease
state or whether they're actually
contributing to the pathogenesis of the
disease we use this as a readout so I
would caution us that we wouldn't make
couldnt and shouldn't make a single call
on whether a drug is effective on
whether we're seeing changes because
maybe they're actually this drug is just
making the brain a little bit more hyper
aware of what's going on but if we if we
look at a specific activation so in this
case with gif AP reactivity we see the
same thing that there's if you compare
wild-type to untreated mutants in the
top left to the bottom left of these
panels you can see a significant
elevation and gf ap reactivity
but this is very very heightened in the
with the addition of lke
suggestion suggesting that LK is making
these both microglia and astrocytes dis
hyper reactive if we look at the storage
material so recall that I told you that
the hallmark of this disease is that
they accumulate storage material in the
lysosomes the same thing is true that
you really don't see any preservation or
any protection with the addition of lke
in the brain either in the cortex or the
thalamus and in this case what we're
looking at is immunohistochemistry for
one of the constituents of this disease
the subunit C mitochondrial stem subunit
C ATP synthase which we know accumulates
in these cells so sort of the take-home
message is that the lke isn't working we
have looked at a number of other crimp -
targeting compounds and it seems to be
the case - that although you can get
some correction at the cellular level
and may be modest phenotypic changes at
the pathological level we're not really
seeing much in in terms of recovery for
targeting crimp - as a as a therapy so
just to summarize this portion of the
talk we've looked at these lke compounds
are these crimped - targeting compounds
to see whether they might have some
potential therapeutic benefits but it
the the treatment of battens disease is
likely going to require a comma toriel
approach so I don't want us to say that
we're going to completely rule out crimp
- targeting compounds because as I
showed you they do have a slight
phenotypic improvement but we really
think they're going to have to be
offered in combination with something
else so that causes to kind of rethink
our strategy in the lab about two years
ago and this kind of came in combination
with working with a sealants 6
Foundation called the Charlotte and
Gwyneth gray Foundation and really sort
of this was a new way of looking at teen
science so our lab in this sort of large
program
aunt sets at the center as the seal and
sticks Patton's disease but we brought
in experts from all these different
therapeutic modalities looking at
anti-sense oligos or using IPS for
disease modeling IPS sees for disease
modeling using gene therapy as a
potential treatment and looking at a
whole host of different molecules and we
wanted to do a couple of things we
wanted to come up with a system where
scientists really were at the table for
the same common angle and not in the in
the program for their individual science
so sort of the innovation in this is
that that all the members of the team
really kind of checked their egos at the
door and are taking this holistic
approach and team science approach to
the treatment of batten disease and
coming up with therapies but the other
thing that we did was sit down and say
how can we accelerate drugs through the
pipeline so many of you are familiar
with schematic similar to this showing
sort of the timeline that it takes to
get drugs through the therapeutic
pipeline and so it might take four to
six years to screen to do say a
high-throughput screen where you'd be
looking at you know five to ten thousand
different compounds through those high
throughput screens you might narrow your
drug targets down to a couple hundred
you would then go back and start doing
some preclinical testing whether it
would be on human cell lines or in
animal models and only after about five
to seven years have you narrowed these
down often time you narrow it down like
we did in the case of lke spent a few
years studying that molecule on
long-term animal studies only to
discover that it doesn't work and so now
you're back at the drawing board before
you would even go into a clinical trial
which in many cases can take six to
seven years to actually move a drug to
market and so we wanted to come up with
an approach where we could actually move
this faster so one way in terms of the
molecules is that we've developed a very
rapid high content screening platform
for moving drugs through in vitro
studies and the short term in vivo
before we would even take them in to
long term and so at each step of this
process we're eliminating drug compounds
and and for the balance of these studies
were really focused on things that are
already approved
FDA compounds or things that are in the
approval pipeline we then screen those
in either mouth lines patient IPS lines
or patient fibroblasts lines and then go
into sort of short-term pathology to
make sure that it's working before we
would ever go into long term drug
studies and by doing this we're able to
eliminate a lot of compounds but
essentially the way that this high
content screening works is you can look
at a number of different parameters and
screen a number of different drugs so
this is just a sampling of the drugs
that we've been looking at over the last
couple of years but essentially you can
look at many many different parameters
so in this case we're looking at a top
at you using a site OID we're looking at
lysosomal pH using lysis sensor we can
look at mitochondrial function in these
cells we can look at cell rocks to give
an indication of reactive oxygen species
for some reason I have toffee G twice
but you can also use high content
screening to you to look at antibody
based or ICC in these patient cell lines
looking at things like the placement of
the lysosomes you can look at apoptosis
you can look at cell proliferation and
then do other assays on top of this
looking at things like mitochondrial
function in a seahorse as they are
looking at cell stress so it really
allows us to look at a number of
different parameters we don't confine
ourselves just to patient cell lines
like fibroblasts we can also look at
neurons and look at the complexity of
these neurons in terms of axonal
specification and outgrowth in response
to drugs and look at a number of
different parameters like look at
synapse numbers and look at unique cell
populations there's a number of factors
that I think that we often ignore when
we're doing high-throughput or high
content screening Aryans even in vitro
assays that I think that these high
content assays really allow us to
dissect so I'm just going to list a
number of these things that we're
thinking about looking at now whether
there's genotype or phenotype
relationships so do different mutations
even in the same gene
two different types of phenotypic
changes are there sex differences so
imbalance disease I can tell you that we
often do see male and female differences
but at the level of the animal
scientists often disregard that
particularly when they're doing cell
culture are there differences in disease
state and progression so with those
different genetic mutations can we see
changes in the disease status and
progression over time I'm going to see
my mouse the the relevance of the ease
of the assay itself so the high content
can give us very reliable reproducible
results that we can rapidly move through
a number of compounds clearly fairly
quickly and then it also allows us to
ask questions about things that are
actual disease indicators versus
functional attributes of the disease and
then we can use these high-content
assays to start layering drugs together
much more rapidly so instead of doing
drug screenings sequentially we can
actually start to put these together so
just in the last few minutes I want to
tell you about sort of our one of our
big success stories in coming up with
this more rapid model and this was
really when we were looking at all of
those different modalities we knew that
gene therapy probably had the likely the
the highest likelihood of getting us to
the finish line the fastest while we
were continuing to look at a number of
those other molecules so we partnered
with the team at Nationwide Children's
Hospital that have been very successful
in developing an AAV 9 treatment for
spinal muscular atrophy they would have
been able to take this av9 SMA through
clinical trials and we're seeing very
promising results in the kids so what we
decided to do is actually piggyback onto
their successes so we package the seal
and six human gene into their AAA v9
plasmid that has a chicken beta-actin
promoter so it's going to give us very
robust expression throughout the central
nervous system there was some indication
that over expression of some of the NCL
proteins might be site of toxic to the
cells so we started off by just
expressing this plasmid in non-neuronal
cells looking to see if it interfered
with self survive
people you can see here that after RNA
and the protein level in these cells
they look completely healthy and they're
able to produce large amounts of ceylon
six if we left or poor ate this plasmid
into the brain of an embryonic day 15
old mouse and allow that animal to
continue to develop out to postnatal day
7 what you can see when we Co electro /
8 GFP with the human seal and six
plasmid is that we get very nice
expression of ceylon 6 in neurons in the
cortical plate it extends into the
processes similar to what we had seen in
our culture model so just looking here
in the red comparing that to the gfp
colo labeled cells what you can see is
that there appears to be no toxic
effects so over expression of these
proteins or this protein in particular
doesn't really seem to have any toxicity
in the animals and and so we move
forward with injecting this into the
mice for an efficacy study the tropism
of a av9 changes slightly between mouse
and non-human primates and humans so in
these particular studies we give a
single inter cerebral injection of the
AAV 9 starting at we give that injection
at postnatal day 1 and then take these
animals out as long as they will live
and so through that intracranial
injection we get nice increase in RNA
expression of ceylon 6 throughout the
central nervous system all the way down
the spinal cord so this virus is able to
spread very nicely if we look at in situ
hybridization for ceylon 6 in the bottom
row you're looking at a probe specific
for ceiling 6 and you can see nice
spread of this virus or RNA expression
of this from this virus throughout
different regions of the central nervous
system and here is really kind of the
the most telling slide so this is using
in the bottom and antibody that is
specific to the human ceylon 6 and this
is in teal and six mutant mice compared
to a PBS injected control animal on the
top you can see really nice robust
expression of ceylon 6 throughout the
central nervous system
all the brain regions that we looked at
from that single ICV injection so what
we've done over time is look at sort of
the recovery of the of the phenotype
both pathological and behaviorally so
here I'm just showing you
autofluorescence storage Matteo the
left-hand column is wild-type the middle
column is ceiling six animals injected
with PBS and then the far right column
is ceiling six mutant animals injected
with the gene therapy in two different
brain regions again somatosensory cortex
and VP MVP Ella the thalamus at three
different time points so on the top
we're looking at two months of age
middle panels is six months and then the
bottom two panels is actually all the
way out for the wild-type in the gene
therapy treatment animals at eighteen
months of age the middle panel is a
comparable image from a 14 month animal
and 14 months of age is when all of our
salient six pdfs treated animals are
dead but our mutant animals treated with
gene therapy continue to live past that
if we look at the subunit see
accumulation at the same time points the
gene therapy is able to stave off that
storage material accumulation all the
way out to eighteen months of age so
it's really preventing the onset of this
disease very nicely you can see that in
terms of Astra Civic activation here
with GFE P+ astrocytes and the same with
microglia and i will tell you that the
microglia in the middle panel this is
again when these animals are more of
them they're on their way out and so
these microglia themselves are starting
to look really stiff they're not just
hyper hyper reactive so they're looking
really ill but in the salient sticks
that are treated with gene therapy you
see a little bit of micro glial
activation but it is nothing compared to
the untreated mutant animals so
behaviorally what is happening to these
animals I'm just showing you a number of
different assays so on the top left this
is rotor rod the mutant animals that are
untreated or at the bottom and our gene
therapy treated animals are
indistinguishable from the wild-type so
the light blue and the black are the
gray charcoal bars are staying together
the same with if you look on the middle
and left hand side we're looking at
Morris water maze as a measure of
learning and memory the mutant animals
are have an inability as time goes on to
find a platform for Morris water maze
but the mutant animals that are treated
with gene therapy are really on par with
with the wild-type animals probably at
the later stages they're starting to
have a little bit of declining you can
see a slight difference but really it's
substantially better than what we see
for the mutant animals their body weight
is maintained they're healthy they're
happy in those later stages at 12 and 18
months of age just even comparing the
wild-type to the mutant animal are the
sorry gene therapy treated mutants to
the wild-type animals they're really
indistinguishable they're they're
grooming they're walking they're
behaving they're very similar to the
mutant animals that you can see from
these class being scores but really this
is kind of the big take-home message is
that the mutant animals are that solid
blue bar that drops off these are the
untreated animals and as I said they're
dead by 12 to 14 months of age but the
survival of the gene therapy treated
animals in the light blue bars is really
on par and these animals are surviving
out to 24 months of age so probably one
of the the best long-term treatment
approaches that we've seen so the next
step of course would be a clinical trial
so what we were able to do in this
particular study is that in
collaboration with the team at
Nationwide we stacked all of those
things that we would normally do in a
very linear process on top of one
another so instead of doing efficacy
studies waiting for those results and
then doing toxicology studies waiting
for those results and then injecting the
virus into non-human primates
essentially building on the success that
nationwide had had we put those whole
processes on top of each other we were
simultaneously injecting non-human
primates at the same time we were
collecting efficacy data which allowed
us to go to the FDA within eight months
of starting the study and receive IND
approval to start a clinical trial that
clinical trial is ongoing at Nationwide
Hospital we've completed the
or they've completed the early phases of
this which enrolled six patients and now
they're looking to expand inclusion in
that clinical trial that's a phase one
phase two safety trial that's that's
currently ongoing so stay tuned to see
whether this is is working but it really
sort of that accelerated pipeline
drawing on previous expertise and
knowledge has really allowed us to move
this pipeline along a lot faster so just
to summarize I kind of go back to this
slide we have a number of ongoing
studies that are continuing to look at
other treatment modalities now kind of
taking the approach that if the gene
therapy continues to be successful what
will ultimately need to be able to do is
offer potentially other drugs in
combination with gene therapy so instead
of even screening these alone or maybe a
couple of drugs at a time we also
conduct these studies in combination
with gene therapy because there's a lot
of unknowns about gene therapy still we
don't know how long the virus will last
hopefully it will last the lifetime of
these children but will we have to have
something else in our arsenal that's
ready to go should the gene therapy
start to wane over time so I'll just
wrap up here I'll show my research team
really a lot of the gene therapy work
that I highlighted was led by Jacob Kane
a postdoc in the lab and two technicians
Katie white and Derek Tim the basic
biology work was spearheaded by another
postdoc in the lab so neo Co and one of
the graduate students John Rudnick
that's helping her finish up those
studies the gray foundation team I've
shown here in the middle the these folks
have been absolutely instrumental in the
work that we've been able to move
forward and that we continue to do our
creme two collaborators and lastly I
just want to recognize our support that
we receive both from the NIH and from a
number of battens of these foundations
and nf1 foundations thank you very much
thank you dr. Jill Eimer for that
informative presentation we will now
start the lac Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started
our first question is what attracted you
to rare disease research I think there's
a number of things that I find
attractive about rare disease research
one of them is sort of the the limited
focus that's been paid to these diseases
over time so even though every single
rare disease is individually rare
there's always over 7,000 rare diseases
and often times you know it over a
decade ago a lot of the focus was really
on the more prevalent diseases like
Alzheimer's or Parkinson's disease but a
lot of scientists are realizing that
that we can glean a lot of information
from rare diseases both on the basic
biology and therapeutic development side
of things so oftentimes we we look at
this as if we can get a drug approved
and to potentially to the market for a
rare disease that same technology or
even possibly even that same drug might
have applications for these more
prevalent diseases like Alzheimer's or
Parkinson's or other neurodegenerative
diseases so I think that part of it is
sort of the compassion for the patients
that there's nobody are very few people
that are fighting their fight for them
but two on the on the flip side from the
scientific side that we could have a
larger impact by by developing tools and
technologies and a way of thinking in
rare diseases that could be applied to
other disorders thank you for that
answer our next question is what lengths
all the forms of baton diseases together
do the proteins involve all functions in
a common pathway you would think that
because there's such a similar phenotype
that there might be some cellular
mechanism that is similar across all
forms of that disease but so far we
haven't we haven't been able to discover
any common feature in fact even though
these diseases are classified as
lysosomal storage disorders there
not even all lysosomal proteins so for
instance CL + 6 has only spends a little
bit of time in the lysosome most of its
time is spent in the ER and so so far we
don't think that there is a common
feature I mentioned PPT TPP one and kept
sandy those are all lysosomal enzymes so
those at least are linked together in
sort of a common cellular function we do
believe that possibly Ceylon six the
sale in three and seal and eight might
be linked together in a common role in
trafficking so there's quite a bit of
evidence that each of those proteins
interacts with some of the microtubule
binding proteins like kinesins diamonds
and myosins so they might also be
clustered together into a common pathway
but you know really other than those
there's not a real common functional
feature what is common is that they all
result in this common phenotype of the
storage material accumulation and a
common pathology thank you okay
it looks like we have time for one more
question our last question is your
studies use ICV to deliver gene therapy
to the brain do you think this is the
best liver method or could other methods
be better so there's actually a number
of investigators even in the batten
disease space that are looking at IV
infusion of gene therapy and part of the
rationale for doing that is that in some
of the forms of batten disease there
does seem to be a long term other more
systemic changes in the bodies of the
ideas could they actually deliver
systemic Lee and and correct both the
brain and the other other non central
nervous system changes that they're
seeing in Ceylon six and the animals we
haven't really seen a lot of non CNS
pathologies we've actually looked at the
mice out to probably about 18 months of
age and really are sorry not eighteen
out to one year of age and we're not
really seeing any non CNS changes that
might be contributing to their death so
I think
in the case of Ceylon sex targeting to
the CNS is the way to go this is the
organ that is most severely affected
that's really you know what's going to
keep these kids alive and then also just
like with drugs the ability of the virus
to cross the blood blood strain
blood-brain barrier although it it does
it a little bit it doesn't do it super
efficiently so if we give an ICD
injection directly into the brain some
of the virus does get out of the brain
to target those other organs but the
same is true if you give the IV
injection you're limiting them out that
can actually go into the brain so in our
cases ICV does seem to be the way to go
really so that we can correct those
neuronal phenotypes or the central
nervous system phenotypes but only time
will tell if we're going to uncover
other non CNS pathologies that
ultimately these these these kiddos are
being affected by I would like to once
again thank dr. Jill Weimer for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I would I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June of 2018 you receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
in this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon goodbye